I'm Kiernan Shipka and I played the
doodle can let it snow I'm Jacob Aslan
and I'm kion and shameik Moore and I
face do it though
hi my name is Mitchell holiday rush
Isabella Merced Mackay not Scott I'm Liv
Houston and I'm Anna and we are gonna
play a game of I feel like I mean I'm
pretty into it I'm I know yeah no come
on it's that's what sorry um I just
think it's like propaganda but like
watch out Christmas might be someone
here probably okay uh yeah he barely
ever has a phone on him and I changed
numbers all the time so it was very
difficult to get hold of it he's often
fine yeah he's off the grid I had one
morning with him that I was in the vent
for like 40 minutes and he came like
shocked he came out to shoveled like any
of the women really jump out jump on the
women thing
and it shows but he's not actually
getting ready nothing
I took a long time on this one because I
have really curly hair you curled little
you fro so it was like straightening and
this and I had different color
extensions and that got so my hair took
a long time and after that I got it
firmly straightened for my next to come
yeah Jacob it's pushing like I
definitely never pulled a prank on
anybody this one and this one giant
sculpture with needles in it in front of
my hotel room at a time when I thought I
was being haunted by demons yeah will we
all about different scenes so everyone
Jacob Jacob just cuz he has his own
script I think I'm in acting since
Peters
oh I'm a meme tagger we did a lot of
like sending each other oh yeah there's
a meme of me looking and these
sunglasses go onto my face and says deal
with it and I seen people it a lot and I
feel like it's Power Move to send a meme
of yourself to something
do you remember when I took it oh yeah
forget this I can't wait
look there's two cameras there they say
just sit down for 15 minutes guys I'm
like fifty minutes I look over and Kim
Ellis we're good
they got amazing while snare aligning I
want cameras incredible singer here oh
yeah everybody how's that chimney I
would point to show me hey guys points
[Music]
no I don't know what it's cannon but
it's always a stupid stupid selfies oh
yeah yeah it's all acting whatever razor
blades
that's fries and whites raised am I
doing this ring fries up lights I was
saying razor blades
[Music]
you